all right it's time for hatred mail
we're a professional voice-over artist
does interpretive readings of the hate
mail that I get here's a quick reminder
about the foundation of hatred mail
because the government that is
supposedly totally inept is the same
government that can pull off a
conspiracy that'll blow your mind
patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom okay a new phrase coined
this week on hatred mail not maggot 2020
MIGA 2020 take a look has anyone ever
seen a mouth on someone as big as David
Park man his mouth is suspiciously big
Park man you're a real distorter of
reality your Biden is falling but Harris
is cutting into Bernie
kofo 'zed you have no sense of
perspective mega 2020 David Park man is
male version of Ellen yeah I am sure
that people in finance are going to come
up with some funny explanations for what
MIGA rather than Magga means i won't do
your job for you i know you are very
very good at this i will simply remind
you that you can send a middle finger
salute to the hey tree 'it's with the
coupon code hey tree at 40 if you go to
WWE at medCom select the membership of
your choice when you're asked for a
coupon code type hey tree at 40 you will
save 40 percent and 1500 hey tree 'it's
will cry every single time that that
coupon code is used very exciting stuff